Cuando volví a mi casa en 1955 de la universidad
en el tiempo de Martin Luther King,
muchas personas volvieron a sus casas en ese entonces
y empezaron a discutir con sus padres y abuelos.
Mi padres nació en 1885,
y tenía ciertos prejuicios en cuanto a las razas.
Como irlandés, odiaba a los ingleses tanto
que no tenía sentimientos para otra cosa.
(Risas)
Pero sí tenía una sensación que las personas negras eran inferiores.
Y cuando le dijimos a nuestros padres y abuelos,
"¿Cómo te sentirías si en la mañana te despertaras negro?"
Ellos dijeron que era la cosa más estúpida que podías haber dicho.
¿A quién conoces que se haya levantado...
(Risas)
... y se haya vuelto negro?
En otras palabras, estaban obsesionados en lo concreto.
Moral y actitudes que habían heredado.
No le prestaban atención a lo hipotético,
y sin lo hipotético,
es muy difícil poder discutir argumentos morales.
Tienes que decir, imagínate que estás
en Irán, y que tus familiares
sufrieron efectos colaterales
aunque no hayan hecho nada malo.
¿Cómo te sentirías en esa situación?
Y si alguien de una generación más vieja dice:
"Bueno, nuestro gobierno nos cuida,
y es trabajo de su gobierno el cuidarlos a ellos",
no quieren tomar en serio lo hipotético.
O imagínate un padre islámico cuya hija ha sido violada,
y siente que tiene que matarla por honor.
Bueno, está tratando su moral
como si fueran palos y piedras que ha heredado,
y que son estáticas en la lógica.
Es una moral heredada.
Hoy diríamos algo como,
bueno, imagínate que te dejaran inconsciente y te violaran.
¿Mereces que te maten?
Y él diría, bueno eso no está en el Corán.
No es uno de los principios que tengo.
Pero, hoy se universalizan tus principios.
Los presentas como abstracciones y usas la lógica sobre ellos.
Si tienes un principio como,
las personas no deben sufrir a menos de que sean culpables de algo,
y luego excluyes a la gente negra
hay que hacer excepciones, ¿no?
Hay que decir, bueno, el color de la piel,
no se puede sufrir por eso.
Debe ser que los negros están de alguna manera manchados.
Y no podemos usar evidencia empírica para discutir, ¿o no?
Y decir, ¿cómo puedes considerar a todos los negros como impuros
cuando San Agustín era negro y Thomas Sowell era negro.
Y se pueden eliminar argumentos morales así
porque no se están tratando a los principios morales como entidades concretas.
Los estás considerando como universales,
para ser consistentes por su lógica.
¿Cómo llegamos a esto desde las pruebas de inteligencia?
Esto es lo que inicialmente me llevó a la historia cognitiva.
Si se mira una prueba de inteligencia,
se observa que los aumentos han sido mayores en ciertas áreas.
El subexamen de Wechsler
es sobre clasificación,
y hemos tenido grandes aumentos
en ese subexamen de clasificación.
Hay otras partes de la prueba de inteligencia
que son sobre el uso de lógica en abstracciones.
Alguno de Uds. han usado Matrices Progresivas de Raven
y se trata sobre analogías.
Y en 1900, las personas podían resolver analogías simples.
Si les decías: los gatos son como gatos monteses.
¿Cómo son los perros?
Ellos responderían: lobos.
Pero para 1960, las personas podían atacar a Raven
en un nivel mucho más sofisticado.
Si les decías: tienes 2 cuadrados seguidos por un triángulo:
¿Qué le sigue a 2 círculos?
Ellos dirían: un semicírculo.
Porque un triángulo es la mitad de un cuadrado,
y un semicírculo, la mitad de un círculo.
Para 2012, los estudiantes universitarios, si les decías
2 círculos seguidos por un semicírculo,
dos 16 seguidos ¿por qué?,
responderían 8, porque 8 es la mitad de 16.
Quiere decir que se han apartado tanto del mundo concreto
que hasta pueden ignorar
la apariencia de los símbolos que se encuentran en la pregunta.
Ahora, tengo que decir algo muy desconcertante.
No hemos logrado progresar en todos los frentes.
Una de las maneras en la que nos gustaría ocuparnos
de la sofisticación del mundo moderno
es con la política,
y a pesar de que se pueden tener principios morales humanos,
se puede clasificar, usar lógica, abstracciones;
si se es ignorante sobre la historia y sobre otros países,
no se puede hacer política.
Hemos observado, en una tendencia entre los jóvenes estadounidenses,
que leen menos historia y menos literatura
y menos material sobre países extranjeros,
y son esencialmente ahistóricos.
Viven en la burbuja del presente.
No saben diferenciar la Guerra de Corea de la Guerra de Vietnam.
No saben quién fue aliado de Estados Unidos durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Imagínense qué tan diferente sería Estados Unidos
si cada estadounidense supiera que esta es la quinta vez
que fuerzas occidentales han ido a Afganistán a poner las cosas en orden,
y si tuvieran una idea de lo que ha pasado exactamente
en esa 4 ocasiones.
(Risas)
Y eso es lo que pasa, apenas se han ido,
y no hay una marca en la arena.
O imagínense cómo serían las cosas
si la mayoría de los estadounidenses supieran que se nos ha mentido
para que participemos en 4 de nuestras 6 guerras.
Porque saben, los españoles no hundieron el acorazado Maine
el Lusitania no era una embarcación inocente
sino que estaba cargada con munición,
Vietnam del Norte no atacó a la Séptima Flota.
Y, por supuesto, Saddam Hussein odiaba a Al Qaeda
y no tenía nada que ver con ellos,
y aún así, la administración convenció al 45 % de las personas
de que eran compañeros de lucha,
cuando se colgaba a uno de la lámpara más cercana.
Pero no quiero terminar así de pesimista.
El siglo XX nos ha mostrado enormes reservas mentales
en gente común de la que ahora hemos reconocido,
y la aristocracia estaba convencida
de que el ciudadano común no podría lograr nada,
que nunca compartirían sus ideas
o sus habilidades cognitivas.
Lord Curzon dijo una vez que
vio personas bañándose en el mar del Norte,
y dijo: ¿Por qué nadie me dijo
que tan blanca era la plebe?"
Como si fueran reptiles.
Bueno, Dichens tenía razón y no la tenía.
[Kipling] dijo, "La esposa del coronel y Judy O'Grady
son hermanas por debajo de la piel".
(Aplausos)